Speaker 1: Let's go to is it Lewis from New
Brunswick or Lois? It's just cut off. I apologize.
Something with an Elmo from New Brunswick.
Speaker 2: Oh, good afternoon. It's Louie.
Speaker 1: Louie. Welcome.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Oh, I just want to
thank you. I love your show.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: It was losing for a long time.
Speaker 1: Pleasure.
Speaker 2: A couple of months ago,
you had a piece with author and Jefferson Morley.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: He's known for JFK research
and stuff. My question for you is,
do you think the government's response to the
JFK case, which a lot of I guess polls show that
a lot of people are a little skeptical on the
official conclusions. Do you think that's fueled
all of this recent. I don't know how to say
destabilization with conspiracy theories and
just lack of like general consensus.
Speaker 1: You're saying is the lack
of credibility of the government's
position on the JFK assassination
fueling other modern conspiracy theories?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Do you think it like it
it like laid a groundwork that we haven't
really reaped the full damage of until now?
Speaker 1: I don't think so. I don't think so.
I mean, there's interesting stuff going on with
JFK right now. In fact, I recorded a ticktock
earlier this week, which we're going to publish.
And Jefferson Morley wrote about recently how on
December 15th, I believe it is, is the deadline
imposed a year ago by the Biden administration
to release a whole bunch of new documents? And
we'll see about the JFK assassination and we'll
see if they are or aren't. And there are some
who are saying this is going to be an incredible
bombshell or something like that. I don't know. I
don't think that no. I don't think that the JFK
assassination specifically has much to do with
modern conspiracies. And I think it's lack of
critical thinking, social media, echo chambers,
people who don't know how to think for themselves
and evaluate claims, lack of epistemological
skills. I think it's all of that, really.
Speaker 2: Oh, interesting. All right.
Thanks a lot. I appreciate the call.
Speaker 1: All right. Louis from New
Brunswick, thank you very, very much for the
call. Let's go to Grant from Ohio. Grant.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. I was just wondering if you
could give your thoughts, because I don't think
you've talked about it yet, about the Biden and
his administration now siding with the
railroad unions when I believe all they
wanted was paid sick leave. And there was
an interesting interview. I think Jake
TAPPER did a pretty good interview with the
judge a couple days grilling him on it. But
I just find it kind of hypocritical
because Biden says he's the most pro-union
and labor president in our lifetime, but
he's not saying what the railroad workers,
when all they want is paid sick leave.
Speaker 1: So, listen, a lot of that was happening
as I was sort of falling into my COVID fit period.
And so I did not follow the story as closely as
I would have liked. But my understanding
of the Biden position on this was, listen,
they're not getting everything, but
they're getting a bunch of stuff they
want. And it's really important to prevent
this strike. Now, you can take the position
that the Biden administration should not be
forcefully working in any way to prevent a strike,
particularly if they claim to support both
unions and workers rights to strike. And I
am very sympathetic to that idea. But it seems
that the argument that the Biden administration
is making is if this strike were to happen,
here are all of the ways in which it would be
a disaster for different aspects of the American
people because of the reliance that is that is
taking place on railroads. And a lot of their
demands were met. And so we think that they
should not strike. But I think it's perfectly
legitimate to say that it's a government
overreach to actually prevent the strike.
Speaker 2: I agree with that, too. And it's also
frustrating when these CEOs and like the leaders
of these railroads, are making record profits,
too. And I just think it's frustrating.
Speaker 1: It is absolutely frustrating.
There's no doubt about that.
Speaker 2: All right. Well,
that was all. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks,
Grant. There is Grant.